welcome everyone thank you for taking
the time in the afternoon on the last
day to come and watch watch me tell you
about how I'd learned C C sharp okay so
how do you actually learn a new
programming language because that was
the problem here I could submit a talk
on learning it and actually get it
accepted and that's how we got to this
point and it's been not kind of on my
background for a long time to learn
c-sharp it's kind of been a thing that I
felt that I should know and and it was
sort of a joke sort of a timeline sort
of a something and it's been quite
interesting so where do I start by
procrastination that's usually how you
start any big plan on how to do anything
and then I asked on Twitter is like okay
so you people know see sure what should
I know and then watch lots of videos
read books and try to get a development
environment write some code take a lot
of notes freak out and then write make a
flow diagram
okay so trying to learn c-sharp my my
name is Patricia else I'm a trainer and
consultant these days I I like to call
myself a C++ programmer I'm currently
focusing a lot on application security I
started my own company or co-founded a
company last year called turtle sec so
if application security is interesting
to you let me know my first real job
after University was at Opera Software
working on the original opera browser
then I was a Java consultant for a
couple of years then I worked at Cisco
making embedded telepresence systems and
then last at Vivaldi before starting
turtle sec so I have a master's degree
in computer science and while I was a
university my main language was Java but
with a lot of other other languages as
well so if you have a baby language
how how does this actually work how do
computer languages become computer
languages do you have some kind of
genealogy do you have some kind of like
my father language was this and my
mother language was this and look at
mini-me and actually probably maybe in
the beginning but in the end it's more
of a cross-pollination it's like it's
it's a good tree but you can kind of
cherry pick features and then you alter
some other syntax and the thing is the
whole thing becomes sort of like a mesh
and so is this good bad both yes and and
that's a lot of what we'll see in this
talk so first of all I'd like you to
look at this little program so the
question is which programming language
is this I'm noting it's a good example
from this programming language I have
but which programming language is this
what about this one
I'll help you
the differences are those actually yeah
let's see sharpen C++ and you probably
didn't know you could write so similar
examples did you okay the thing is these
are pretty much evil twins and they
don't really mean the same thing the
syntax is is very similar but the
semantics of the two programs is widely
different c-sharp and C++ are very
different languages so you could write
two programs that look almost the same
but mean very different things and this
this makes learning a new language hard
and so while I was learning c-sharp I
was also thinking a lot about this and
then my my daughter who's a language
nerd she started talking about learning
languages in general like natural
languages and actually learning
languages natural languages is something
that there's science around so I started
to look what what does the science of
natural languages what does that have to
show me and so if you're an English
speaker and you want to learn Spanish
then you take a word like telephone and
you try to spanish i it and then you try
to go for a telephone oh and in this
case this is right and the reason why
this is right is something that they
call in linguistics cognate related they
have the same origin in the same form
and the same meaning so this is great
this means you can basically skip over a
lot of things you can get by with like
guesswork and and this is true a lot in
programming as well but you have other
things that like much and then trying to
go for mucho in Spanish which is right
in this case too but this is actually a
false cognate and the reason for that is
that these are the same form and meaning
but it's by accident
they're not actually related
linguistically but seriously who cares
because your mental shortcuts are
working and if you can do that while
learning a new programming language
you're basically just using the
experience that you have and and
guessing what things mean and most many
times that will be right and so you can
fast-track learning in their language
and so you look at a program and then
here you have some c-sharp and it's
quite straightforward we have some sort
of printing to the console thing and
this is a little bit different from
language to language exactly how you say
write something to the console but you
know the console where it is pretty
similar from JavaScript and so you kind
of guess what this does you have some
kind of VAR it's not totally clear if
you don't know anything about c-sharp
that this is statically typed under the
covers but it is um and then you have
some kind of Lists where you put
integers into it so you basically feel
like okay I can get this you have some
kind of for loop it doesn't list can't
instead of size or length but you know
it's pretty obvious and you have a for
each which is also you know it makes
sense so looking at this do you think
okay so there's no real surprises here
you can think that c-sharp is an
imperative seed like language and I I
know imperative c-like languages so this
I can do right but then you can look at
the same list again but start to think
okay so maybe I can do this instead to
write to the console it's the same list
but now that's not really looking very
imperative and see like anymore it's
looking maybe more like a functional
Lisp like language
so these cognate SAR great but sometimes
this algorithm of mapping what you know
to something you don't know doesn't
really work out so I know ijen we have a
word called Pig and in English there's a
word also called pig and so if a
Norwegian not knowing
which very well tries to form an English
sentence they might say I had bad pigs
in my debt in my tires unfortunately
unfortunately piggy Norwegian is stud or
nail so it did not mean what you thought
it meant right and this is a pro a pro
problem they call false friends so these
are words that sound the same and look
the same but mean different things so
they have the same form but a totally
different meaning and you see that in a
programming as well so these false
friends they give you bad assumptions
and and these this is the time when your
mental shortcuts your guesswork your
Spangler fiying is hurting you right
same thing you have in Spanish I don't
know if you have Spanish speakers but
the English word embarassed spano fide
is very easy to jump to embarrass ah
which means pregnant I did that
unfortunately okay so and a special
short like a special version that I call
driftin meaning of false friends is
something that I'd like to look at so in
a Widgeon we have a word called focused
in Danish they have a word called flucos
said in a Danish way which I can't say
um but in a region it means breakfast
and Danish it means lunch when [__]
which is really unfortunate because it's
sort of like the same context you'll see
it in and so you will think that you
know that it's definitely we're talking
about a meal and and this is a drift in
meaning because these words have the
same origin the same form but they mean
now different things so let's look at
some programming eye things in this
right so you have lists in Java you have
something called the list and in c-sharp
you have something called a list in Java
a list is a linked list it's actually a
data structure you usually don't use
because it's caught
quite inefficient and it's mostly
academically interesting in c-sharp a
list is actually in what in Java they
would call an ArrayList or what be in
C++ will call a vector and much more
interesting data structure but if I see
the word list and my language is Java
then I will think it's a linked list
because that's my mental shortcut so
there you have a drift in meaning of
course they have the same origin the
same form it's like all of this it's
like everything is Lisp if you go far
enough back and in Lisp everything is a
list and but they don't have the same
meaning so you have this concept of an
origin where things came from what the
words mean or the contracts the
constructs mean and and what form they
have and that form can change there can
be different from language to language
to express the same thing
so you have the cognate and the false
cognates and in my opinion who cares
doesn't really matter if something was
actually related in some kind of
programming language hierarchy the most
important thing is that your shortcuts
are working right they have the same
form and they have the same meaning so
guesswork will actually work for you
the problem is when things look
different because if they look different
it might be hard to know what they mean
but usually surprisingly what I realized
doing this is that things that are
different in form are usually ok because
I can tell from the context what the
word does like what is this thing I can
tell from the program context what it
does the hard part is the driftin
meaning because this is when I make the
bad assumptions this is when I think I
know what it means but it actually means
something else and that's the world of
the false friends so how do you learn
when everything that you learn is based
on what you know because then it becomes
very interesting what I know if I'm
going to learn c-sharp than what do I
already know so my absolute first
programming language was scheme which is
a it's in the Lisp family of
which is so it's a very functional
language and that was my first
experience programming well it made me
fall in love with programming but I
quickly ended up doing more imperative
programming so I was doing Java at
university lots of other languages as
well but professionally I've been mostly
you doing C++ and C but I've been
programming and maybe yeah 15 20 maybe
languages in my career so I have lots of
lots of different examples of
programming languages in my experience
and some of them I'm really bad at I'm
really bad at Perl
i I've done like I've coded
professionally in Perl and Perl
programmers will shake their heads at my
code and and that's also something that
I found interesting in this process is
that you can have an accent in
programming and and and the thing is you
know now like if you think back if you
come from one programming language you
start coding in another programming
language in the same way
that's an accent and and my accent in
Perl was C and so I so all of the probe
programs were like okay Patricia you
basically you're treating this language
like it's C and I was like but it works
and and the same thing and then some
cultures are very strong like in Python
community if you come in programming
like it's C or Java or JA then then they
will get really annoyed because they'll
say it's not pythonic it's not idiomatic
the word idiomatic means you have an
accent if somebody says it's not
idiomatic they say you have an accent
from another programming language and so
I've been programming from 20 years ish
so this is this is my mental baggage or
skill sorry to know sometimes the other
thing is if I'm going to learn a new
programming language I'm not going to
read 700 pages book from cover to cover
it's not going to scale and I'm going to
throw it away before I start so I need
some way to figure out what to skip I
want to jump ahead jump past all of the
normal stuff right
because the languages are inherent
inheriting from each other and
cherry-picking features from each other
so I should be able to skip lots of
things um but the problem is the false
friends I think I know what it means but
it actually means something else and I
probably should have read that chapter
but I didn't know because I thought I
knew what it meant or the unknown
unknowns like what are the things that I
I'm skipping that I actually should know
but I I don't have a reference for and
so I make a plan I'm going to skip over
all the contents I'm gonna try so I'm
going to at least skip the beginning so
all of the this is a for loop this is a
variable this is continuing if else
what does break do in a loop all of
those things is like we're skipping
those and but how do I know I'm not
missing things so now I'm getting
stressed out about the thing because I'm
skipping too much right so now I'm
worried I'm missing important things so
maybe I should like skim maybe I can
watch like the videos on like twice
speed just just to make sure like then
maybe there are some like nuggets in
there somewhere and this is where I
think programming education is failing
us because we should have like a like a
two page summary in the beginning of a
book that says you can skip to chapter 5
after reading these two pages and it's
like yeah all of the four loops are
normal all of bah-bah-bah is normal var
isn't actually aesthetically type thing
dynamic is not and just like it's just a
quick introduction and then skip to
chapter five so how do I learn the
basics and how do I find the surprises
because the problem is to find the
surprises I have to go through
everything and there's way too much
repetition because you have all of this
cognate all of the things that I wanted
to skip and there you find things that
have drifted and meaning my false
friends suddenly become weird things
like namespaces and defines so I'm going
to use this kind of structure a little
bit so I'll show you so this the the
language in the little box there is my
recognition language
so this is the language I was thinking
of when I learned this thing like this
is how I mapped it in my mind
so namespaces I mapped to C++ because
the syntax is very much the same it
looks very similar this is how C++ also
looks ish and but the thing is this is
c-sharp and the semantics are a little
bit different I would probably say that
c-sharp namespaces are probably more
leaning towards what what is going to
become modules in C++ which has like a
totally different syntax and and so I'm
not sure and and this is going to trick
me because I think I know what namespace
means and I don't know what namespace
means and c-sharp has defined
I mean seriously this this was so much
fun I'm lying probably the only one
that's actually found this fun but you
can do this you can you can have
defiance in c-sharp and you can use them
to do things and you probably shouldn't
but you can and again this is this is
not really defines the way I know them
from C and C++ this is there's no real
preprocessor this there's like almost
like 90% of everything you can do with
the C++ preprocessor you cannot do with
c-sharp defines so it's this is a this
is a false friend for me and then
probably for a good really good thing
you know buddy probably wants me to use
defiance in my c-sharp code and but it's
it's possible so if I have an accent I
might actually do this I am coming from
C++ programming c-sharp I'm maybe this
will this will influence how I code but
then you have things that are easier
right
like cognates operator overloading
optional parameters named parameters
instruct value type operator overloading
is something that I like it's very
controversial in most languages but I
kind of like it I like to be able to
express semantics in this way saying
that I want this box and this other box
in
one bounding box and I can do that with
plus over the unions you can have like
plus and minus and things like that I
like that and having things like that's
like okay I want to have this first and
this second and I want to add them
together to create the bounding box
around them and then that box will have
the right dimensions and I'm not going
to go through all of this but I like
it's nice it's a static function but
it's possible so then you have optional
parameter arguments and and this is also
most languages it's like is it good is a
bad I don't know but sometimes it's
useful and so you can do that in c-sharp
so that's interesting i I you know
that's that's the one of those things
where I will find them interesting you
have name parameters which I also find
interesting we're getting some named
parameters syntax the C++
probably not as powerful as yours but
but there will be something and I I kind
of like it I don't know I haven't
programmed a lot with this kind of
constructs before but district'
now this is where it's like you're
coming home it's like welcome so
starting in in c-sharp is is very close
to two to c++ in in soul and and that in
the meaning and the semantics of it is
very similar and that's really important
because for me structs have a semantics
even in c++ and because you see those
bus trucks are basically just classes
but they have but they have public
access this is not true in c-sharp they
actually have private access you have to
write public but but they're very
similar in the way that you treat them
you have a little bit of a drift in form
but i would still say these are cognates
this makes sense to me and the only
difference is in c++ everything is a
value type so as long as I stick to
thinking to being able to move
like think of values only as structs I'm
okay but this I like this I don't think
Java has a hast value types yet anybody
know
and so this is something I miss when I
program in other languages I really like
value types but then you have just
inform and and these are surprisingly
okay I have properties in c-sharp and
properties are surprisingly popular
because coming from most other languages
all of the setter and getter stuff has
become very unpopular in most languages
so you basically say if everything is
public they just have a public field
just get over yourself it's not more
complicated than that
but I think the reason why it's so
popular actually primary reason is this
it is quite a nice syntax it's very
compact it's very expressive and it's
very easy and I think that the read this
is one of the reasons it's very popular
the other reason is probably how you you
compile and link things together it
makes it a little bit better having
functions versus fields but but still I
think the syntax is is a big reason why
this stayed popular in c-sharp and fell
out of fashion in in Java well okay it
depends on who you ask and but there are
like cool things you can do like you
just drop the set and now suddenly it's
it's it's a read-only property you can
well of course I had to try if you could
just drop the get and just have a setter
right only property and but apparently
that's not allowed and but you can do
similar things you can make the get
private or make the sub private which is
probably more reasonable
it's a strange thing to have a field
that anybody can write to I am but
I encountered this kind of syntax and I
was really wondering why would anybody
do this but then I realized this was how
c-sharp people implemented properties in
the beginning because I asked on Twitter
why would you do this and of course you
could do this if you have more elaborate
logic but I saw a lot of code that looks
basically like this and I was like why
would you do this and not do the simple
syntax but apparently that's the legacy
thing but overall I think properties are
kind of nice and and and for me
properties are more related to cute and
in cute they are very powerful mechanism
to have the bindings to the UI and if
you haven't tried cute and qml I really
recommended that it's really really nice
and then you have this magic value thing
like G's
VI for me everything is new I didn't
know I had never written a line of
c-sharp before I started learning at
this time and so you have you have out
parameters now this was really
interesting to me that you have a
specific keyword to say that this
parameter is an out parameter I don't
think I've seen that in other
programming languages um but semantics
wise it's fine the one thing that I
thought was nice was this this one part
here where you can actually declare it
in the call that's interesting I've
never seen that either but for me it's
semantic wise it's fine it's basically
you're passing an int by reference so
that's fine I don't have problem with
that and of course it was hard for me
and this is something I saw many times
that people don't explain concepts in
like common words and so you kind of
have to figure out what does this
actually mean that wasn't the worst one
though I'll get back to that later but
then you have no conditional operators
and these were surprisingly simple to
understand so so we have this function
here get coffee which takes a list of
coffee shops and then index it's not a
very it doesn't make sense programming
wise but you know stay with me I have a
thing for coffee and so so the algorithm
here is if there are any coffee shops
and there is a shop at this index
then I want you to get me coffee from
that from that shop and if not just give
me zero which is kind of long but it
just turns out to be like this question
marquee thing and it kind of makes sense
there's a lot of question marks in that
one line though it's like I'm not really
sure about this but but yeah I think
that could this could grow on me
and it just kind of fits together quite
nicely so I like it but I had some false
friends and you've already seen sort of
my biggest false friend coming from C++
to c-sharp is this destructor slash
finalized method and the reason and this
would probably be surprising for most C
sharp people because you don't use it do
you no but the thing is C++ I would say
if you'd find and dig out the heart of
C++ it is the destructor it is the fat
like like if you really reached in and
just grabbed that that is c plus plus it
is the destructor and it was killing me
because c++ finally the C sharp fighting
lasers are also called destructors
sometimes um and they look exactly like
c++ destructors but they are a little
more like Java's finalize which is an
absolutely useless method um because the
problem is it might be called by the GC
maybe it's it's like there's not even a
contract that it will ever actually be
called and even if it is called at what
time it's totally you don't know there's
no reason to put anything interesting in
this function so for me it becomes noise
right this is something that has it has
the same form but it the meaning is
totally different different and it's not
really useful and so for me became like
a sidetrack I had to figure out what
this function does
I thought it was important and it wasn't
so that taking us out like of the sin
text and I have to try to understand the
semantics and this is like how do you
think when you code in c-sharp
what is like the middle of c-sharp
beyond like just the basic syntax yeah
there's some some imperative language
influenced there's some functional
language influenced but what is what is
C sharp E one thing that keep it kept on
coming up in books and in in videos was
this I disposable and of course now it's
like back to my my destructor feeling
it's like I disposable I need to look at
this and and I disposable is quite nice
it's a little bit similar to Javas
closeable and so and it has sort of the
same functionality but I would say
probably in c-sharp it's more elegant
you have more constructs to use it it's
it's especially in later versions of
c-sharp so I I actually like it better
with these using a syntax there's a the
driftin form but I understand what it
means I have a mental model of what this
means and so it's quite easy for me to
learn so it has the same semantics
different syntax but you know I I can
learn that one thing that was harder for
me was yield return and and that's
because my Python isn't really good and
I really felt an Esso so probably in my
next language I really need to learn
well it's probably a Python because my
Python isn't really good and but I think
my Python is better now for learning
sure but you have you have this
innumerable thing and where you you can
return the next yield return and this
becomes and I was trying to figure out
what this was and it took a while
because I need to find the words in my
head to map things and so I I called it
a lazy iterator of course if you're
coming from Python you probably call it
a generator
but I didn't really have that mental
model so for me it became a lazy
iterator and John skeet who was so kind
and sent me his book seriously I had in
his in this book actually this really
cool example so this is this is a
generator generating Fibonacci numbers
and that's all that's all the code and
it's using this mechanism and being this
being that lazy means that you're
basically just getting the next
Fibonacci number every time you call it
I thought this was really cool you
probably think this is totally normal
but I'm not used to this so I thought
this was really cool it kind of brought
me back to my Lisp writ
I'm like oh okay so where this is very
functional and then I found extension
methods and people on Twitter they were
really talking about extension methods
they were like oh extension methods are
one of the really cool things in in
c-sharp and I had really nothing to map
that to but I agree it's pretty cool
actually
and especially in C++ I think we would
like to have something like this because
we do have very sports interfaces
sometimes and here you can actually add
functionality to existing third-party
code and I really like that so you have
this target class and you want to add
some functionality to it and it has no
functionality currently and so I can
make this function called print hello
which takes this target T and does the
thing and that means later on it just
magically kind of appears and suddenly I
can add functions to existing classes
and add functionality to them and I
really I I thought it was quite cool and
I think it could be very interesting in
other languages but how do we teach
because the thing is again I'm coming
I'm coming as a programmer I know how to
program don't teach me how to program
using c-sharp because I'm not interested
I how to program
thing I know I want to learn c-sharp
so how do we teach someone who already
knows how to program and this became
something I would kept thinking about we
need to use terms that that people
recognize and this and so us I'm going
to show you the place that I got stuck
the longest learning c-sharp you're
probably going to think it's a silly
place to get stuck because the problem
is when you when you use terms that
people recognize then you can also say
okay this is like this other thing but
this is how it's different or you can at
least you give people a feeling of which
mentals headspace you should be in like
what is the mental model somehow and
then you can manipulate it and then goes
much faster if you don't have any kind
of mental model you have to learn it
from scratch and this is I have an
example from a Norwegian because this is
this is again like the unknown unknowns
in a region um okay you know when it
when you have snow on the ground and it
melts a little bit and the top part of
the snow it freezes again it's sort of
like an icy layer on top of the snow and
you can actually like you can actually
grab it and like take it off and like
these sheets in no region we have a word
for that we call it scarred we have a
word for that that is crazy if anybody
comes from Spanish or anything that
there's no way they can guess that we
have a word for that and and that's the
problem and that's the thing that
started bothering me more and more are
the things that I didn't understand that
sounded like they were new and sometimes
I realized that they were they were just
using language I wasn't familiar with
but sometimes I was worried just about
what are the things that I'm missing
that I don't know to ask for so delegate
delegate took me a long time I watched
several videos on delegates several
actual like like a plural there was like
a plural psych course on delegates um or
they had a
of other things but I was really focused
on the delegates part because it sounded
really really important like people were
talking there versus it was a key word
for this
it's like delegate they had like a whole
key word I'm imagining this to be really
important I have to understand then
people say oh yeah but it's used a lot
in things so after studying delegates I
can tell you it's a fancy function
pointer so let's look at fancy function
pointers and so you have a delegate it
has a delegate signature so you have the
signature of the function so here we
have a public delegate void prints me
it's the function signature for a
function pointer you can define the
function and then you can use it so
function pointer type function
definition function call see if I had
been given this I've been spend like two
minutes on this concept instead I was
watching video after video of people
talking not understanding what this was
and why it was so important why why are
they talking so much about this thing
there must be more and there is more
because it's not just a function pointer
it's a fancy function pointer so we have
to get to the fancy part okay so the
fancy part here is now we have we have
to write so we're using the same
signature we had before which was the
print me signature and so we have first
and second both are functions okay
are you ready for the fancy you can plus
you get a function pointer plus another
function pointer and you get a third
function pointer and so what does the
function first that prints hello and the
function second the prints of world
print when you call hello world which
series like this it was kind of cool I
don't know it was kind of cool you have
defined operator plus for function
pointers and not only that does like
operator -
well so you can actually like - a
function pointer from another function
pointer and apparently even my IDE
thinks that's a bad idea
but it is possible and I found this to
be pretty cool I'm not like yeah I've
never seen it before but I kind of liked
it so that's the fancy part of the
function pointer in delegates and then
of course somebody comes and talks about
events and event handlers and blah blah
blah and I thought we are on a totally
different subject but actually event
handlers is just a predefined function
pointer type so event handler is a
function pointer type that is predefined
by a by C sharp and you don't have to
think about it but it's all the same
thing it's basically you have to define
a function and now you can use this
function and of course we can use that
than the null question marquee thing
syntax and you can use this for
callbacks or click handlers and things
like that and it's nice but it's not
like earth-shattering and it bothered me
so much that I spent so much time trying
to understand this concept because it's
it's not complicated if I'd been given
the right words and and and I think
that's that's probably one of the
problems we have when trying to teach
programming to programmers we actually
have to use words that map to what they
already know and not treat everyone like
they don't know how to program because
most people who learn how to program
know how to program and and we keep on
teaching like people don't know anything
like you have to start okay so this is a
computer you know in movies when you
shoot the screen ok the screen is not
the computer the computer is like the
box that you don't see we we need to
teach the beginners but we need a better
way to teach experienced people we need
some way to know what to skip we need
some way to figure out what to pay
attention to because that was my problem
what are the surprises and they kept
bothering me all the time what are the
surprises what are the things that I'm
missing and and the first thing that
brought
that home was decimal this is like a
like real big moment for me do you know
about decimal is this like something
people use no okay there's there's the
type in c-sharp called decimal there's a
nonzero base DeRay okay that's weird and
then you have the knowable types but the
decimal thing that really really
bothered me because here you have a
whole fundamental type that I'd never
seen before that was just listed among
the other types it's like is and this
was an example of the things that I
would miss if I was skimming or jumping
over things because decimal is some 128
bit floating point type with 28 to 29
significant digit precision okay so this
is okay so who cares okay who cares yes
because that doesn't exist in any other
language that I know of so I had no
reference I had no reason to believe
that this thing existed and this
bothered me because the moment I saw it
it was an example of what I was afraid
of there are things that I'm missing by
jumping right but then he had nonzero
base to write and this was not good and
the code code looks terrible and I think
that is a good thing okay so I'm not
going to go through it you can create a
non zero-based array in C sharp and you
should not do this and it is clearly
demonstrated by how ugly it looks but
it's interesting because why why do you
have nonzero base to race somebody
thought this was a good idea at some
point okay
but nullable types because those were
also a surprise I I learned about
nullable types when learning about the
like the question mark dot operator and
because suddenly people were talking
about though this is a nullable bull
and I was like a nullable bull you have
a bull question mark now now I've seen
in some frameworks in C++ you have like
a three-state bull which is yes no maybe
which is always bad in in in Java
they've always made these kinds of
things by having like a boolean object
and then the pointer to the boolean
object can be no and so then you can
have null true and false and and as we
saw with with with like the out keyword
in the for an out parameter and our
parameter in in Java would be would be
the same you could have an out parameter
that would be an object and then you can
mutate the object they don't have this
concept and so one of the things that I
like and struggle with in c-sharp is how
it has made syntax for things that in
other languages are just constructs you
make up there's actually native syntax
for a lot of things that don't exist in
other languages and that's good because
it makes the code nicer and especially
if they're useful things that people
like to use but sometimes I it makes me
wonder what am I missing
like the boo question mark which is it's
it's nice but it you have again like we
saw the question mark question mark
before I my question my question mark is
if maybe is null then which kind of
boolean value should I take instead so
this is like a sort of a default value
kind of thing which in in C++ you could
probably do just maybe or true because
we do that we can interpret it as no
value as in the truthiness kind of way
which it doesn't exist in c-sharp but
then I found some JavaScript loved
because I was coming at C sharp very
much from Java C
C++ kind of direction and then adding in
maybe some functional stuff but I I
didn't expect to find native support for
JavaScript T things so you have
anonymous types they syntax Weiss looks
a little bit like JavaScript and then
you have the expand or object expand or
object is somebody who really really
drank their JavaScript juice we'll get
back to it first anonymous types and I
think it's kind of nice if you kind of
squint a little bit and and just kind of
not see the new stuff it looks kind of
like a JavaScript object and and it can
be very nice for it especially I would
imagine this be really nice and tests
because it makes it pretty clear um but
the expander object people this was
awesome okay so you're here finally we
have dynamic which is quite a cool word
it's very long like you had the VAR and
then you just like you could have gone
for like didn't or something to like
match it but no it's like dynamic
expander object and this is basically a
JavaScript object in c-sharp and it
means you can do like weird but cool
things you can do in in JavaScript and
like this I can add a field and then I
can access it like any other field like
it had it already this is one of the
weird things that you can do in
JavaScript which is also one of the cool
things you can do in JavaScript I've
never really understand if it's bad or
good I don't know but it is it is and
you can even add functions so we can use
this function pointer things from before
and now we can actually add functions to
objects that are dynamically created so
you can dynamically create objects with
fields and functions and everything I'm
not sure how popular this is like how
many of you have actually written this
in production code one two yes
this is probably like one of my most
like happy surprises I don't know why
but this is kind of like I don't know
that there's you have this this culture
that is very serious
like you know like very much as much c++
influence and and and and java influence
and then suddenly you're getting more
and more functional with all of the the
linky stuff and then it's like cool
we're just gonna go all out javascript I
like it anyway but if you're going to
choose the language and I've been
thinking about this a lot in the last
few years especially because we're
getting new languages like go and rust
and and they have like really really big
fanboy communities and and then I have
to think like what would make you choose
a specific language over another
language
what are C sharps killer features and
before I started learning c-sharp
I would people kept telling me that
c-sharp is like Java the c-sharp isn't
really like Java and I mean that in a
good way but I need a list and it can't
be just like why would I choose it over
another one because it can't be just
nice to have things if you know what
language you will pick the language you
know most likely because it's easier but
what surprised me was that the reasons I
would choose c-sharp was none of the
things that I've shown you already and
the primary reason would probably be
platform integration I had to think
about this for a long time because this
is something that's really bad in Java
platform integration in Java is horrible
if you ever wanted to call like a
platform library on Java that is like
the worst thing don't ever do that and
so I would say in this respect c-sharp
now being much more portable than it was
and even moving to being even more
portable in the future I think it's
probably rivaling go which I didn't
expect because one of the
issues of go is is is good platform
integration while at the same time being
a safer language and so I would actually
say that that go when C sharp are much
more competitive and style and probably
also Python then Java in that space and
the other thing was link of course
because everybody told me what is the
like the best thing in c-sharp everybody
told me it was linked and it took me a
long while just to be understand all of
the syntax I had to learn all of the
delegate stuff you know took a long time
but I got to link and I have to say I
like it but I like it in the same way I
like sequel and that's that's that's a
hard hard thing it's it's and it's funny
how they you have both types of sin
taxes you have this extremely functional
magnetic kind of interface and then you
have this very sequel like interface but
I would say that if I had a funk had an
application that where I needed actually
to do real sequel like operations
I would prefer c-sharp and I would
prefer c-sharp over basically every
other language and it's funny that those
are the two things because for me coming
to C sharp I thought c-sharp was a
Windows programming language but I've
been programming c-sharp exclusively on
Linux the entire time of course I
started off really badly because I
googled how do you run c-sharp on Linux
and then and the first hit was installed
mono whoo that was a rough rough first
start but but thankfully Twitter steered
me in the right direction and and I've
been very comfortable programming
c-sharp on Linux and I think especially
now with cloud and everything and then
having good platform integration from
c-sharp to Linux
and having things being properly
portable I think would make c-sharp a
very good back-end language for a cloud
and and better than go actually because
go is still very young and it's still
very small it's not as expressive and go
has some nice features with very high
level like concurrent paradigms but but
there are also a lot of that in c-sharp
now with a sink and a weight but it's
not as as expressing maybe as go but
probably will be so I was surprised I
liked c-sharp a lot better than I
thought I would but back to how do we
learn because that became the thing that
I thought about all through the process
how do we actually learn how to program
a new programming language and I came to
the conclusion that this is the best way
to learn a new programming language
rewrite an application you've written
already take something that you know how
it works you know all of the all of the
all of the things it needs to do that
you've written it in something else and
then rewrite it in the new language and
the reason for that is is you don't want
to think about application logic you
just want to focus on language how do I
do this thing that I'm used to doing in
this way how do I do that in the other
way and basically in the beginning
you're basically stack overflowing all
the things but you have you have some
kind of framework to put it in you have
some kind of mental model to put it in
so I think this is the best way but it
still needs what are the unknown
unknowns what you don't know what you
should Google you don't know that Oh in
c-sharp the idiomatic way to do this is
to use this thing if you don't know the
language then you don't know what is
idiomatic and this bothered me because
how do you get confident how do you feel
that you know a language
when you're basically just mapping from
your previous language how do you know
that you're proficient in this language
how do you know your idiomatic how do
you know you don't have an accent
because you have all of these
overlapping things of inheritance and
cherry picking of features but what
ended up bothering me were they unknown
unknowns what are the things that are
missing what are the things that I don't
know I should know so then I started to
think back because I have done this
before
I I didn't know like I went to my
interview at opera and they had sent me
like this programming test and I'd
written them my and my program and sent
them to them and then they were sitting
there with my program on pages like you
did and then they and one of the guys
goes oh yeah but you know C++ and I'm
like no and they were like and everybody
kind of stopped and looked at me you
don't know C++ and I'm like no the first
program I ever wrote in C++ was the one
I sent you so how was it so I started in
my job because I didn't they were they
asked me so what do you know and I was
like I know Java and I know some C and
they said oh yeah yeah okay you're good
it's like okay spoiler alert I was not
good I was not good at all um but what I
did was basically they gave me a CVS
password they said here's a browser and
go make features CVS was gifts for old
people anyway what I realized is the way
that I learned C++ is probably the best
way to learn a programming language it
is to make something interesting because
if not you're just going to throw it
away and not bother to iterate over
you're not going to live with your
mistakes you're not going to refine your
code over time so make something that's
interesting but the most important thing
is you need to sit next to someone who's
knowledgeable and kind because those
other people are going to
look at your code and go like yeah yeah
yeah this is gonna work but it's not
really idiomatic this is not really how
we do things in c-sharp we would do it
in a different way and that basically
means I think that programming learning
programming is a social activity and as
a senior senior programmers a big part
of their role is teaching and and and we
and coming back which I've talked about
many times this peer review process I
don't think it's very interesting to
talk about what's good or bad but using
it as as a way to teach that this is how
we do things so this code that we looked
at before it's very clear that you can
have an accent in code and I have a
clear C++ accent in this code and that
we call that oh it's not idiomatic
c-sharp and is definitely not but where
do you start if you're going to learn a
new programming language because that's
where I started right I'm going to learn
this new language how do I start and I
procrastinate what stay tuned for one
it's very easy to stay in procrastinate
it's very hard to figure out where to
start and so I would say probably
anything that brings you out of
procrastinate is a good place to start
whatever it takes to get you to actually
start is good maybe even submitting a
talk to a conference thank you very much
[Applause]